[Music]
josiah is with us in omaha hi josiah how
are you
doing well thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so i have a vanguard retirement fund
that tracks it's just a mutual fight now
you always didn't get confused etfs
mutual funds but attracts with the you
know stock markets and what i was
reading is that we're going to enter
into a bear market and
that one article suggested i invest i do
dollar cost averaging um invest in
commodities i was looking at a uh mutual
fund that just temporarily did you read
the article that said you're supposed to
send it all to dave ramsey or john
deloney yeah um because that article is
out there too no it's not it's not out
there but
just because you read on the internet
doesn't mean it's right
yeah matter of fact that probably
invalidates it
that's true
so otherwise i wouldn't be here but it
would still be you know i know that in
times of
volatile times you know you're not
supposed to have major emotional
reactions like exactly
but
he who right he who jumps off a roller
coaster in the middle of the ride is he
who gets hurt
finish the ride my brother exactly
finish the ride my brother
so continue to invest but i just you
know what the right question i guess is
like the 10 000 millionaires that we
studied that became millionaires
the number of them that jumped out of
their investments into commodities
because they read an article and that
made them wealthy when things were scary
in the news was precisely zero
none of them did that
none of them did that they kept
investing and they kept investing and
they kept investing when it was scary
when it was wild when it was fun when it
was good when people are smiling when
they're frowning when they're cussing
and when they're singing joyful noises
all the time they just keep on investing
just keep on investing just keep on
investing you can call it dollar cost
averaging if you want to call it that
but that's not the advantage to it the
advantage of it is you don't stop
investing and you don't change horses in
the middle of a flood
while you're in the middle of the stream
you're gonna drown no no no no no no and
quit reading stupid butt articles on the
internet because it'll cause you to do
this stuff
man i got a friend that got cancer or
he's got a cancer scare yeah may have
cancer may not
and um
i said listen do not listen the cancer
might get you but i will 100 guarantee
you i'm going to kill you if you google
and start reading about cancer on the
freaking internet because you are going
to get bad information a bunch of goobs
on there with opinions about
tomato seeds or whatever else they dream
up and i'm going to pound you if you
open your computer and type in the word
cancer there is one
whenever i see articles like this i
always go to what's the incentive and
there's somebody who's got a commodities
trading office that makes money on the
exchange that looks for precisely folks
like you josiah who are trying to pay
attention who love their families who
are a little bit scared and they say hey
come over here come over here and you're
going to jump off and you're going to
give them your money well let's do it
the other thing is this very very seldom
do you actually get conned by a real con
man right but you can get conned by an
enthusiastic ignoramus
and there's a whole lot more of those
than there are con men you just
described social media
i did you did one phrase what phrase
this is the ramsay show